[Music]
the following is a presentation of the
st louis chess club
the spring 2021 season of the saint
louis corporate chess league
in an unusual way as mike cummer
attempts to both
host and play for one of the teams
and now your host mike comer
match four of five and all culminates at
the final four
on may 20th why you ask
am i wearing my money jacket cause i'm
feeling like a
million bucks after getting my second
pfizer shot and i will be playing for
the merits corporation tonight as i used
to work
down at one of their subsidiaries back
in 1999 quality controlled
services and i will be playing none
other
than moneyballin of
enterprise the reigning champions of the
corporate chess league but tonight they
do not have
their number one star john
boyer time boyer so they will be led by
chess
hulky so it should be an interesting
match
we are just awaiting the challenges
coming up
it should uh should be challenging here
at about
6 15 usa central time
so let's see some standings here
and remember you want to be on the left
side
because if you're not on that side you
are not
going to go to the final four and that's
what we're all
leading up to so as you see
edward jones they're doing well
233 and a half grand prix points
enterprise they came up strong
last time around and got 121
points wwt 115 and a half
wade's got the brilliancy prize for wwt
last last time around and he gets a
lunch with
me and club manager development manager
ryan chester
at the brand new kingside diner
right across the street from the st
louis chess club
express scripts 110 and a half
and then there's a big gap but but as
as you know in the corporate chess
league
these standings are can fluctuate wildly
ascension has 91 merits
right behind in sixth place with 90
points
we got a lot of work to do today
dougherty
85 points unfortunately doherty only
is bringing three players today though
so
it's going to be tough bear they need
that they need to add some points
72 and a half arco with 43 and umb
rounding out the field with four
so those are the standings how do you
get these grand prix points you might
ask
so you play a team match okay
and if you win your team match you get
an additional
20 bonus points if you draw the match
you get
10 uh points each and for
every win you get
you will receive one grand prix
point these these matches are
back-to-back games you play one with
each color against your opponent
and uh it's game and ten no delay no
increment so
never resign in these games because
anything can happen
especially when your opponent gets under
uh two minutes or so it
the blunders blunders galore so we
should be uh starting any minute now
let me make sure i'm on live chess i'm
awaiting
money ball and challenge i can see if my
uh
i've only played one other game on
youtube with my money jacket
it was the blitz bounty gangsta
edition if you want to check it out and
uh
check out the rings and the bling yeah
and uh anyway it worked out pretty well
for me
i didn't lose a hundred bucks let's just
say
big spoiler alert big spoiler of it yeah
and we came up victorious so hopefully
i got two games tonight against uh
moneyballin with enterprise and then uh
two games in round two so let's check
out the pairings for round number one
of course we have the rainy champion
enterprise against merits
wwt will be playing edward jones
so that's a huge matchup so
one against three so
and then uh bear has arko
ascension against express script so if
ascension
oh moneyballing is uh
accept all right here we go c5 no matter
what
ascension against express scripts and
then we got some extra game so so we are
live
all right so he's in the carolina court
so this is this is a well uh for
for novices it's uh very very exciting
to play uh
the the caledon court um ben feingold
actually uh beat uh a national master
in like 20 moves and he wasn't even in
the best condition to play
that saturday morning game too but but
he's like i have the white pieces i'm
playing a national master i i will not
name him he's actually a former
club champion of the saint louis chess
club
whenever they play e4 you always just
take it
they get castled i've got ideas of
knight
to a6
and oh check all right check how do i do
i want to open the
no i don't want to open the thing
yeah sometimes d6 in certain lines in
the caledon court can be uh
detrimental but nobody really plays it
now i'm joking i don't actually want to
go here i want to go here
and he fell for it well actually if he
plays d6 here i'll just take it
that'll be fine
no he's forcing my hand though to play
d6
my light squares aren't looking very
good right now
so let's trade our light square bishop
actually let's attack his queen first
now whenever you take the bishop off the
back rail guess what
that pawn is a target now if he plays
like queen to b3
very exciting playing for the merits
corporation uh
i did work in a subsidiary
the the uh executive director tony rich
got me that job too
down at uh down in sunset hills back in
the
late 90s so that was nice of him all
right yeah i don't like his uh well
actually why don't we play
here
[Music]
yeah i don't know if it's good or bad
but at least i get my queen out
i guess he can only attack it with his
knife but i can just take it so
i don't know i might have played bishop
g4 here
maybe i should have played bishop g4
all right so what is going on maybe play
bishop back to g7 oh nope he's attacking
my pawn
can i get away with e5
or do i want to prepare it with rook
over so if he takes i'll take with the
knight
and then i'm attacking up there
and whenever in these competitions
whenever
uh the opponent has a chance to take on
passant
he's a hundred percent gonna do it so i
could almost pre-move knight takes e6
but i'm not going to because that would
be a fools
you only want to pre-move if you know
pretty much uh guaranteed capture or
something okay so he's attacking my guy
so he can't
he cannot play on passant anymore
[Music]
all right so i'm playing a trick
right now so if he's not careful i'm
going to play g5 and trap his
bishop i always play for tricks
always playing for the tricks
ah check it out vaccinated for
covid19 one step
closer thank you to all the all the guys
over at cvs pharmacy it was great
i actually had to go down to cape
girardeau like
three weeks ago to get the shot he was
so desperate for it but i said
give me your best shot and they're like
okay we got the fires are just for you
buddy
so what is this guy thinking about okay
all right
all right do we even have to calculate
no
all right this is looking good this is
looking good
the jacket is prevailing
so so my plan is queen to g6
now what if he plays queen to d2 here
am i just gonna cry
oh my gosh
yeah shoot that's why you needed to
calculate
oh where's that knight going where's
that knight going
he needed to play queen to c1 i guess
oh man chess is a
that's why chess is a great game you
know
it's just one little square away
it makes a world of difference
all right i'll take a free night if you
insist mr mooney boom
then he's going to get me with check
yeah just take it what are you thinking
about let's go now i do not want to play
queen of g6 here i'll say he wins by
rook
okay so we're gonna have everybody
guarding the
seventh rank here
and hopefully maybe we can follow some
more uh
games
follow maybe swap he's our board
one right now i am actually playing
board
two for the um for the merits
corporation he is playing uh
chess hulky see what what he's up to
looks like they give chess hulky a
slight advantage but i
i don't know exactly what's going on in
that one
all right he's still thinking about
follow i am rounder
he actually won one of our brilliancy
prizes back in uh
november
it looks like they gave him uh
they give him a slight advantage that's
good
and then we have a ringer gary
mendel 66 the
ceo of color art is also on
on team merits
he he won the brilliancy prize and uh
it looks like he's down by 22 points
yeah you can't win them all
all right i gotta get back to my game
though like quick
oh my gosh so he's got
so how many people does he have on one
two
three and i have so take take
take all right
i'm going to bring my rook over
or why do i just get out of the pin
everybody like that idea
bishop takes rook takes
queen takes queen takes rip takes
all right now he has to trade
so i like this i like this
oh and i'm in a pin again
he just loves putting me in a pin
why don't i'm up a piece so i could just
play knight to
eat whatever right now you want to just
do it now
and then we can figure out my rook
situation later
that way it pretty much forces it sure
oh and it defends this pawn cool
gosh because if this pawn goes my whole
gosh he'll have a past pawn and this guy
is so weak
man this guy i need this pawn
oh no i just lost
oh no
the agony of the feet
the agony of defeat
i was just saying i why don't i just
play rook to g8
well let's make sure i can't like
not lose and i was almost thinking about
going
to f8 when i
all right let's get the let's at least
get a point for the team
that was uh not good let's just say
oh man oh man oh man moneyballing got me
money bowling got me so we can
add a win for moneyball in here
and gary mendel the two ringers are uh
0-2 for merits
the caledon court the coloring court
it fizzled out
all right but there's always the next
game here
so we'll see i'll see how it goes see
how it goes
i was too distracted by the other games
that's that's my story that's my story
so i cannot say i'm undefeated with my
money jacket anymore
which is a it's heartbreaking
heartbreaking
but i am rounders doing pretty well
oh yeah i think we got one more guy here
to follow
steve r19 he's the team
captain of merits
and it's a dead equal game it says so
it's a team game too so
we're gonna pick each other up hopefully
and uh good things will happen let's get
back to my game so i don't lose on time
here
he played a6 preparing b5
i'll just let it happen get g4 going get
h4 going get h5 going and just hope
hope for win
all right so he's pinning my knight i
don't know what that does so
i'll just get on with the show
b5 take
i'll take it why not
why not
he's got ideas of night night somewhere
maybe and the big remove the defender
man i can't believe i just didn't play
rook the g8
and then i could have played my night
over
i just wanted to get that rook off the
board so bad i guess okay
what's this night going okay so bishop
you did your job
oh why don't you go here i kind of like
that
all right now let's get the king side
attack going
i don't even know if that's a good move
because now he can just play bishop to
a6 probably
but oh well what is he oh no
how embarrassing it's all falling apart
yeah put in my boo he plays that
first huh
i mean who can blame him
i need to get castled in a hurry here i
need to get castled in a hurry
moneyball moneyball actually came up
really big in the
final four last year
his game against edward jones to
ultimately uh force the armageddon game
in which
john boyertime boyer won knight e8
josh do i really want a castle here
oh check oh how did i not see what was
going on
oh my gosh i should have just got castle
like i said
this is not good
i'm thinking about checkmate or
something though the whole time and
it's like there's no checkmate guys
all right now how do i get the checkmate
oh i got an idea
all right first good move of the game
maybe
probably not but oh my gosh
you can probably just play rook takes
night here
oh man
this guy's full of tactics tonight
i just need to get this checkmate
it's all i'm going for is checkmate here
i can't even play the move i would want
to play if
because he's got if i if i do threaten
checkmate he's got rook to e1
check oh right he didn't see it all
right now i can try checkmate
deal deal
all right how are you gonna stop
checkmate how are you gonna stop
checkmate
all right
oh man rick takes knight was just a
crusher
but i'm not out of the woods yet
we gotta figure out oh maybe swap our
board one
gets the big victory over uh
chess hulky all right so we're on the
board we are on
the board
oh steve r 19 the the captain
nope we can still get it out stalemate
is not gonna happen in this one
so i'm gonna put yeah so the the captain
went
down
all right you cannot stop checkmate he
cannot stop
checkmate he's like shucks
do i even see checkmate oh all right all
right please say you see
checkmate here like if you don't see
checkmate here
you're in a lot of trouble mister
oh i think i see maiden two
please say this is made in two check
okay check this is not a joke
and then bishop h6 mate
yes i didn't even believe it at the end
because i thought he could go
back on c uh c
is uh his bishop on c3 so check out so
check out this game
if he just plays rook takes knight i
think it's an absolute crusher
yeah if you guys at home for
49 chess.com platinum membership is
great you get
all this uh all this great thing they'll
make fun of you they'll say you play
like uh
33 accurate
one missed win i bet this is going to be
the missed win from
from him when he plays uh
and then we'll get to the other live
games in a second here
oh this is the missed win bishop takes
b5
is a blunder knight takes e4
yeah whatever yeah
bishop c6 is another blunder but
knight e8
oh man they just want him to sacrifice
knight takes
either pawn here because right then his
bishop's coming down so when he plays
knight e8
it's just not as precise i guess
check knight takes e3 they wanted me to
play
or wanted him to play
so now yeah rook takes e2
now they even like rick to b7 but the
whole point of rook takes e2
is like i can't threaten check mate
because he can play rook to e1 check so
i have to take
and then buy my rook and now i guess i
can threaten checkmate
but oh well well
i got on the board for merits somehow
someway so let's check out uh
what else is going on here now i can
check out the
the youtube comments i bet they're not
uh all that flattering tonight
after
after that uh debacle in round one
i am rounder wins uh
for uh for
merits so we have one two
three and points looks like they have
three points
all right very exciting stuff this is
neck and neck against the
reigning champions of the corporate
chess league
let's uh get go to uh good old youtube
st louis chess club
and and just so you know ben simon my uh
my computer is
on mute so we don't have to listen to
any kind of ads or anything
we got 47 players watching today
all right honest bishop hello
the night move was very unnatural i
agree
all right let's check out some of the
games
what we got i am rounder plus
seven so let's see what's going on here
he just gave a big check he had a
blocker
and now pawn takes
he's got ideas of a
g7 check get a queen
or maybe just get your queen on f7 with
checkmate
see what we get going on
how can big daddy jazz 64 get out of
this
it doesn't look like he might not be
able to
oh maybe swap got two games for
the board one yeah without john
john boyer leading the team
enterprise might struggle tonight
hopefully well
hopefully will they even be able to hold
on to one of their final four spots
it's very tough to drop from the two
spot to the fifth spot
but i have seen it happen
but it's very tough to fall so far but
as i said
these uh these standings fluctuate uh
time and time again this is match league
match
four of five and then
we'll play the final four may 20th
may 6th will be the fifth and final
installment of the regular season of the
spring
season we will be having uh the fall
league so if you want to register for
that
uh ben simon can i show um the website
yes no maybe all right so you go to st
louis chessclub.org
go to this join and give tab and then
the corporate chess league
and we have the parents for the league
match
and then we have the grand prix
standings after league match
number three hopefully we'll be able to
uh to add up the uh
the standings from tonight and then
spring league registration obviously uh
they mean the fall league but uh
you can contact uh contact the
development department
and uh or just
follow the website and uh
yeah for sponsorship or membership
questions please contact the development
department at development
single with chessclub.org that's uh
headed up by uh lauren stewart
and ryan chester and ryan chester is
also the club manager
all right back to the games
see what we get
i think that one's already in the books
all right he did get the queen and he's
got mate in two can he
see it can i see it
up it looks like uh it looks like he's
going to play his queen to e6
next move
if i had to guess i might as well be the
best guesser
i'll get two i'll get two right
so i am rounder went 2-0
so maybe my uh my big
win my comeback victory
could be the difference
we have five points so far one two three
four
five oh no
but we need five and a half points to
clinch the victory
all right so can gary mendel
66 save the team here
come on gary just threaten checkmate
buddy threaten check me
yeah there you go but he's gonna force a
queen trade probably with g5
but if not there's checkmate oh
come on gary just try any
check any all checks are good
give them another check
just get you can't lose on time you
cannot lose on time just keep going keep
going keep going
queen to g3 here just try to try to keep
the pressure going
just whatever you do don't lose on time
oh there is correct
now we still have one more game in the
books with steve r19
in case gary mendel can't figure it out
all right get bring your rook up to h3
come on
got 20 seconds to check matum who cares
about this other rook you're just going
for checkmate
buddy 12 seconds you gotta move you
gotta move
now that other rook has nothing to do
with nothing
just any kink move two seconds
yeah i mean with with game 10 no delay
no increment it is tough it is tough
all right the team captain's gonna have
to come through it looks like
all right 21
gigawatts wins by time out and he got
two points
for uh for the enterprise
corporation two three
four all right so it's all
on steve r19 it looks like he's down by
two points here well
according to the computer but if you
look at the uh
material it's looking good
bishop to e6
why didn't he just take this pawn you
either need to
guard this pawn or get castled here i
would just like to get cast well guard
the pawn just play
don't play rook to b1 just play b3 here
right
you gotta save it all right castle uh
i'll take it i'll take it
so steve r19 is 1200
and kendalum is 14.50
oh but but does that mean
both uh both of these guys don't have uh
too much power it looks like
all right save the queen somehow someway
just you gotta move i mean
you got to move three minutes this is
a huge huge
game so if we draw
we clinch the match
i mean there's one way to look at it on
my end it's like at least i got
the one point that even puts us in this
position but
i guess you want to be greedy and one at
all oh man h3 let's go
let's go just because he's attacking
your pawn just
move it
nope i mean he's going to get a big
check but it's not the end of the world
what is this guy thinking about
we'll probably start round two
around seven or 705 i would guess
because it looks like all these games
are winding down
we will have uh updated scores with uh
all the other
uh big matches
like wwt and edward jones played
bear played ascension against express
scripts
ascension was trying to take their
fourth and final spot
so we'll see
how how it's going maybe uh our
td nick risco
is updating the spreadsheet here let's
check it out
all right
he's got edward jones with
two three four five and wwt with
three
he's got bear beating arko six
to one
ascension 2-2 against express scripts
and um
and doherty umb
looks like they won by default four to
two
and club manager and development manager
ryan chester won both
his games to deprive uh
i believe uh wwt uh
two additional grand prix points
all right so we really need to draw
this match somehow some way
you gotta play faster gotta play faster
but i like it
that was a quick move just
just try to get him under two minutes
and then
and then maybe the tide will turn if he
can just kind of
i know that's a tall order to catch up
when you're a minute behind in the clock
but just keep
moving you know keep it rolling
and at least kendalum is thinking now oh
oh he can just take the rook he can just
take the rook
and then after bishop takes he can take
the queen come on
come on that's a tough tough
if i didn't see the the the evaluation
bar i might not have saw it but
once i saw that there was a tactic oh
please
and then maris can go on to beat the
reigning champion enterprise if he can
see
knight takes rook and he does now he's
just he's got
what is what is that uh 75 seconds to
figure it out
oh and what's great about this is after
he takes the queen he can take the
bishop i know
it's not for free or nothing but just
consolidate the pieces
yeah now rook over and knight takes the
bishop
takes the bishop
okay okay
he's got a minute 10. you got to move
yeah good good
knight to c7 let's go let's go move it
or lose it
oh the team captain steve orr could come
up huge
for merits he's got a minute to win it
as they say
going to be a tough tough tough win if
he just yeah you can't think for 10
seconds on this move anything's good
wow can the team captain come through in
the clutch
all we need is a draw somehow someway
oh rook down work down
rook to e2 come on
oh
yeah i don't even know who's winning
anymore he's got all these past pawns
now
oh man but it was it was close
get that rook out of there 29 seconds to
try to figure it out it's gonna be tough
it's gonna be tough he's got a big chuck
might as well play
oh it bye bishop
oh he's got rook look to there again
yeah time pressure is a beast
maybe you can get a stalemate somehow
somewhere with three seconds to go get
that stalemate
i gave it a
a great effort a noble effort the team
captain
but it was not meant to be enterprise
and
merits tie five five
so we each we split the 20 points so we
each get
15 apiece not a bad way to start the day
i guess
but what might have been
uh we will uh you want to take a quick
break ben simon
all right we'll see some games i i doubt
there's any more games going on
oh we haven't even talked about the
founder
of the corporate chess league alex
corford
with edward jones
he's got two seconds to win it
he's up by 56 points
nope
oh man 62 point advantage
sweet 62 as they say and uh
the flag it gets ya it gets ya
but i think uh edward jones is uh
in great shape
maybe not one two three five
and wwt if if that
if that's accurate two
three four five seven
nine edward jones
edward jones with all the grand prix
points two thirty three and a half
they did leave home their board one v
shawl and i believe
10 john also
also did not make it today so
wow wwt
making an impression
wade split his games as the dv dutch
so very interesting so those
may or may not be accurate scores so far
obviously we're not adding the 20 point
bonus
or emira's case the 10-point bonus as we
split our match with enterprise
all right when i come back there will be
no
well maybe i'll take off the jacket
i've got my uh i've got my my
i've got my my
st louis archbishop represent and of
course
as caleb demby says he never leaves home
without his medals so maybe i'll be
wearing my medals when i come back
and we can see the official scores and
who knows i mean marist might might end
up winning this
thing if edward jones is uh is having an
off day today so
so yeah it looks like pretty much
all the scores are in
we'll probably almost start the uh round
two
momentarily i forgot my microphones on
the
money ball and things so
all right round two is coming up
and i will be playing uh board 2 from
bear corporation now this is just losing
now that's a guy i think i can beat
hopefully
hopefully i'll come up in the clutch
as as maybe my teammates
so it was a total team effort to get
that uh that draw against enterprise so
so that was good
all right it looks like uh
our great tournament director nicholas
risco has uh
the official standings here you want to
check them out ben simon
all right hot off the presses bear oh
who
who merits his plan that's who that's
who you want to play i
try to keep explaining that to people
you want to play
people ahead of you in the tournaments
that way you can catch up
and you don't have to put uh you know
you know you you can take care of
business all right
so bear with 31 wwt
also with 31 they like to bring as many
players as
possible so that's how they accumulated
so many points
ascension they must have beat express
scripts
so ascension without their team captain
uh mr uh
we're going they came up big
25 points enterprises and merits 15
points
it might be tough to catch them express
script
7 edward jones say it ain't so
five points umb4
doherty two arco one
edward jones will be playing arco in a
round
two express scripts will be playing
enterprise
wwt against ascension so
i would assume if
if that game is decisive
that's maybe the winner
of course bear could come up huge
against merits
and they could win it all so
it should be uh should be good
wwt looked pretty strong they beat
edward jones
and they brought a lot of players so
they might be the odds
on favor to win
spring league match
number four four of five so
wwt if they could win this they might
almost
have a guaranteed spot in the final four
after all
all said and done tonight they won't
have
edward jones's kind of points but
they'll have a
they'll have a flurry of them that's for
sure
so i am awaiting the
challenge from now this
is just losing hopefully i can come up
huge
tonight and redeem myself for my game
one
flub and these were yeah these were the
uh
the grand prix point totals
after the three events so that's not
including
all the points that were just one
literally seconds ago so you see edward
jones
233 and a half just eclipsing the field
enterprise with 121 wwt
added a lot of points to their uh
to their list so they are now
essentially
flip-flopped with uh enterprise right
now if on the live standings
because wwt got more than a
six and a half point difference in
enterprise
express scripts 110 and a half did
ascension
did they catch them where's those lives
standing so ascension has
25 points so 25 plus
91 that's 116
but express scripts got seven
so right now in the live standings
express scripts has 117 and a half
to ascensions 116. that's how close this
is and wwt just has a few more points
better than enterprise right now
i guess i can do the i guess i can do
some math 115 plus 31
is a half 6 40 146 and a half
and enterprise has 136
with their 15 points so wow so wwt is
taking a
about a ten and a half point lead
and merits got up into the hundreds 105
so we're still trying to where's i mean
we're still
if we come up big against bear here
anything can happen and bear they join
the 100 point club too
72 and a half plus 31
103 and a half to merits is 105. so
right now merits has a one and a half
point
edge that's why nicholas risco our td is
so important because
like fates can change with one
wrong click of a button you know but but
we know
nick risco he's got he's got this
spreadsheet down to a science
and it's i i can vouch for it that it is
accurate
but very exciting stuff and right it's
uh
this is going to be good
so we still have one more event after
this so plenty of rounds
still to be played so anything can
happen
may 6th when uh and we really try to get
the pairings where
there'll be some exciting matchups like
enterprise edward jones
whoever the 4-5 match will probably be
playing
so should be good
should be good
let's see we're still awaiting a
challenge here let's
check out the the broadcast here
all right they are trying to i think the
challenges
are uh are going out
so hopefully
all right let's oh oh yes i'm still here
chess.com
i'm still here but i don't see any of my
other uh
nobody else is really uh
really coming up big about check out my
uh
my first game real quick
and see what the computer is going to
make fun of me about
let's see the caledon court game this is
the game where i
totally totally missed that could have
gone either way a very dynamic game
i did have a missed win and a
and a major blunder that was a sharp
game all right well i don't feel
well i do kind of feel bad about it but
at least
help the team get the uh
get the draw against the reigning champs
so that's always nice
let's see uh let's see how much i
actually had a lead at one point
i just got a breeze through the game i
mean we lived it so
they don't even like g5 here
because a queen to be one queen to be
one oh he's turning into trade queens
interesting
oh i could have just played queen to g6
here
okay what happens if he just takes
oh i removed the defender
is it really that easy
but i want to get in live chest anyway i
want to
i want to make sure make sure that uh
we do have online tournaments at the uh
at the st louis chess club we will start
those back on uh i
believe may 7th
so
all right hopefully this guy will be uh
so we do have a game going just not my
game
this is our board one against bears
board one
see if this guy can challenge me
can i get this this screen off of here
uh
ben simon do i know what i'm doing
oh here we go
alex crawford his game is now going
all right and now we gotta we got the
challenge now this is just losing all
right
board two so we got some games in
progress here so
so this should be fun all right
he's got 51 seconds to make a move here
i always place e5
good luck have fun i love your
commentary thank you
thank you all right
i always want to butter up your opponent
before the game
always yeah before you
take them out to slaughter yeah
that's an old michael jordan trick
back in the 90s all right i do not want
him to play
bishop takes f7 check
all right do i know what i'm doing
probably not but maybe i can trap his
bishop he's nope he's not gonna let me
he's too good for that
i usually like to play g6 and everything
but this guy's really not being very uh
cooperative that's the word
castled all right bishop e7
oh man
so not much is going on in this game
i'm just playing a boring chess ben
feingold would be so
happy of me right now
try not to do anything really in the
game just get
castle get developed and just let the
game pretty much just go
just come come to me i guess so
i mean i can't be happy i can't be sad
but now i'm saying that i should just
get castle but now
i just i just have the urge to play
night here even though i know it's a bad
move but
why don't you just get castled and have
fun
nope i just can't resist and then he's
just going to play bishop f4
and laugh at me all right fine i'll play
like you've been fighting gold castle
we're very lucky in uh 2010 to have uh
ben feingold move here from uh michigan
to become our grand master in residence
and uh
he basically got he basically
what his big job was was basically just
to uh
just to do a lot of private lessons with
uh
with the staff here and he got everybody
and i mean everybody at their peak
rating within like
six to eight months so that was great
all right steve r19 our captain is now
online good we need you steve we need
you
this is a tough game
this is not a very mike comer game
usually it's like that first game
against the
moneyball and that's why i'm wearing my
silly jacket
all right i can't resist
or can i resist i guess i'll resist
just shuffle my pieces but yeah i like
to play
tactics exciting games i don't like
really like to play like this
because i don't even know what i'm doing
i'm just shuffling my pieces around
just trying to have some fun
somebody's got to break this thing open
but i don't think i can
but i do have a slight edge on time
which
believe it or not is a big deal in a
position like this
knight to e2 well if he's gonna move his
knight around
i'll move my knight around
this is not a threat because
if i take he'll just play rook to b1 and
then he'll come down
i'll move my bishop and it'll just take
this so it's not a threat
but
knights like to be on f8 right
yeah this is a snoozer of a game all
right he finally broke it open
all right so the c file is open
my pawn is weak
does d5 work nope
does e5 work nope
this is not oh am i like
that bad at chess just look for your
captures
so if i take with the knight
he'll take and then this could get
zany knight takes knight takes bishop
takes and then he can come down and take
bishop takes but then i can play bishop
takes paul and
check
like ben feingold he would never go for
this
he'd be like i'm too old to calculate
this stuff
all right well
oh or else i get the fork though so if i
play bishop takes
and then he plays knight takes knight
takes and then after bishop
takes he can come down and
well he can't threaten checkmate there
i mean you're always supposed to take
with the knight not the bishop but
but i'm threatening that big fork
all right let's just do it
oh eagle eye
two two two zero zero one the board one
for uh for bear
already has beaten our board one maybe
swap
i was very happy when i found out that i
was playing board two and did not have
to play
um this guy
i do remember him from uh he actually
directed one of our first tournaments
here
in 2008 thanks for chess
so that was a fun tournament i got to
actually play in it
i think i won the brilliancy prize
when there was such a thing
all right so is he going to play bishop
takes h6 if he plays bishop takes a says
i'm
playing bishop takes a f2 check
and then i'll take the pawn and then
i'll just hope that my knight can defend
defend my king
oh and then i got ideas like bishop
i'll be all right
the tournament director nicholas risco
is online on
chess.com all right what do you do work
b-1
okay so he's defending that pawn okay
let's just get my
bishop out of here now the big thing is
do i want to attack his knight
do i really want to trade my bishop for
his night
i don't know oh i could play queen
to b6 here
then he'll play what queen to e2 oh
let's put him to the test
oh michael why are you putting them to
the test
let's put them to the test let's put
them to the test
so my big threat is oh my gosh okay so i
am
under five minutes and i have less time
than this guy i gotta start
start going like 42 seconds for that is
uh
irresponsible
but at least i made one move in a tenth
of a second so that
would take the good with the bad
whenever you pre-move on chess.com
they do take away a tenth of a second
but you've got unlimited pre-moves
if if your opponent cooperates
text nick risco here
okay so we played there all right let's
just get
get this guy out of here
very exciting day playing for the merits
corporation
alex corford won his game against the
arko the founder
of the corporate chess league all right
i gotta start moving
king f1
probably not uh probably not ideal move
but
oh that's because right now he's got a
if i could just get rid of this pawn
somehow
oh do i dare play bishop takes pawn no
let's just get well let's play
my knight up here what were you doing on
f8 anyway
buddy
i need to get this rook to
d8 i think so now my pieces are at least
have like some life they're not just
sitting around on the back row besides
my rooks actually i could play rook here
work there
i'm not playing like that who took me
all right he wants the bishop trade well
you got it all right
now what do we have going on
okay so my pawn is under attack so i
will protect it
simple enough
if i could just get this a pawn i think
i'd be doing
splendid
339 so he still has a
time advantage but i've got plus one
according to the computer
according to the scoreboard not nothing
not the evaluation bar as you see there
is no evaluation bar on there
all right rick the b3 okay is attacking
my queen so i'll move it
oh i'm so tempted to take it
but i can't
there's like one one mistake it was just
you know
i'm playing i played pretty pretty solid
for 24 moves and
just one mistake and then i could be
toast
rook to d3 rook to d3
i think that's going to lose the game
for him
well he yeah because if he moves his
queen i play bishop b5
lights out oh he needs to play queen to
d2
i think that's his only way out but but
it's uh this is going to be tough for
him
his only big advantage is he still got
this uh
well that doesn't help that doesn't help
his codes
all right get that rook get that rook
now just because it's in a pin doesn't
mean you you automatically have to take
it you know you can you can keep trying
to attack the pin piece like with uh
knight here or f4 or something
so don't just like oh i got a bishop for
a real good look at me
yeah always want to attack the pin
pieces you know not just take them
i mean obviously sometimes if you're
going to get the pure profit
and there's no other way to attack it
then you take it but
but you really want to keep pouring it
on
all right so he got out of the pin so
now i have to take
i am going to offer oh i could play
knight to e5 here
i really do want to offer that queen
trade but
now let's just keep keep the pressure on
all right i got two minutes and 22
seconds to win this let's let's
let's like like like whatever i was up
so much in that first game kind of
and uh and i ended up blowing it so
let's just keep moving two minutes and
17 seconds all right let's buckle down
and win this
win it for the team win it for the team
i took it
shucks
well let's go let's go move it or lose
it
this guy has had this time advantage on
me the whole
game
a minute 47 seconds
can he do it i don't know
i don't know
maybe
all right good things are coming up
here comes b4 that might
do it this might do it
yes all right i got a minute 37 seconds
to win this position i think i can do it
i think i
can i think i can
come on come on come on
i knew he was going to play there i knew
it i knew
how did he know how did he know
just take the pawn look oh don't take
the bun
and give this guy a check
oh shucks
a threatening rook to up and then the
rook to h1 mate
quit checking me it still has this
time advantage on me it's very obnoxious
it's very obvious
i just need to get get this queen off
the board and
win
uh
all right rematch helpline
all right here comes the big rematch all
right
you got on the board for the old
merits corporation oh my gosh
oh my gosh i do not know how to play
against this
just let them have it let them have it
let them have it
oh
not my best game not my best game
all right so we gotta we got a big win
we got a big win
see if he wants to trade the knights
maybe i've
played like that i don't know
get castled alright playing a little
safe playing safe
chess that's good
all right so he's got two guys on here
can i get away with b3
checks
b3 is gonna have to be played
i'll make sure i can get away with it
i guess i really am gonna have to look
at a book and see what to do when they
play e5
i know there's this guy preston that
works here he beat like a
a little kid that was rated like 18 1900
he's now a
chess expert at 2100 but he beat him in
like eight moves with that
yeah and then and then tell her what i
want okay
i'm gonna have to hide for a second here
all right he's hiding he's hiding
you got it ben simon
did you get it's right there oh i
understand
okay got it got it all right good
all right he's back in business
all right ricky hey what's going on
should we play rook to e1
i don't know we're c1 remember
all right over protect over protect so
this is a tough tough game
one to one
but now i'm going places now i'm going
places
this is when uh you want to start
thinking about the the match
the match
vindy beat steve r
our fearless team captain steve r
steve r19 i should say
oh hey you got it can't can't be in here
come on brittany
ben simon can just go get your thing you
gotta
just go go talk to her
she's right outside
all right can can i win here
all right let's get this bishop
out of here
oh man i probably did not want to
open that file
just let's take a break
say the word
um
i am rounder drew his game
he's our third board for merits see if i
can survive here
the scoreboard says i am plus one
does it even matter which way i take
this
is it just going to be a draw
maybe i gotta go i don't know if he puts
his knife there i can
take it no matter what so he'll play
check maybe i can get out of this
or maybe i'll get checkmated i don't
know
all right now what is he how is he
threatening this
does he even have any checks after this
how is he plus um only plus
two i guess he's got a lot of pawns
hopefully this game will mean something
every point counts in the corporate
chess league though
gary mendel 66 he's got his opponent
down on time but his opponent might have
mate in four here
but he's making a run for it i like it i
like it this is gonna be good this is
gonna be good
oh that was a good move that was a good
move
i guess i'm on the my move queen to h2
[Music]
i got to make sure i don't get
checkmated here
but what is the threat
oh is i'm going to get checkmated on
oh here we go here we go here we go
now i'm making the threats
i don't even know if this is good for me
four minutes and 16 seconds this guy
always has a time advantage on me
this would be embarrassing if i lose
this up a rook
maybe i can just take a draw
one bad move and i'm gonna get
checkmated huh
so queen to g2 check is the threat
well maybe swap got his revenge
man i might just have to take a draw
here
well what's he really threatening here
so he's threatening queen to h3
check then i just move king to g1 right
oh he's got queen to h1 check
then i play king to f2 all right well
let's
let's just try to win i guess for the
team maybe i should have taken a
oh if you're going to give me a pawn
i'll take it
all right now go back here
two minutes and a 36 seconds
it looks like i'm gonna have to win this
one maybe
i'm only plus four on the scoreboard and
have a rook but
oh okay that that was probably a mistake
on his part
now my if my king can flee i should be
okay
hopefully hopefully
but i don't know
is he out of checks now
i do not want to get forked or anything
like that
so he's got to move his knight well
maybe knight to g6
and then i'll bring my rook alright
actually if he plays knight
to g6 maybe i can
just attack it with my bishop
so we play
what's the threat
oh maybe rook to h2
all right two minutes to try not to get
checkmated
did you at least tell her what i wanted
ben simon
yeah all right
it's a fiasco here at the chess club
but you won't want it any other way
always always fun times at the chess
club always
especially if i can win for merits
somehow some way
so his thread is rook to their check oh
my gosh my queen is undefended too
oh my gosh annie's gonna win my guy
oh my gosh michael
one minute oh one minute
oh man i might win this guy's night here
on come on come on one minute to win it
one minute to win it
i gotta just gotta get the queens traded
off and then
i don't even know if i even wanna do
that i don't know how i'm gonna win
because none of these pawns can even do
anything for me i can't win with a rook
and a bishop
in that amount of time
this is tough this is tough this is
tough
he's got a minute to win it
come on mike just do something here
this is when you just pre-move and just
play as fast as you humanly can
and that's not very fast for me
oh i tried to try to try to move so far
so far
just make sure no stalemate i have 33
seconds to figure out this checkmate
i like my chances
all right what a game what a game with
12 seconds to spare
all right we get on the boards for the
merits corporation
two big points so let's uh let's start
adding up some scores here
that was a real battle but you earned
the win
thanks chess.com good games you're much
better than me now that's the joke
i had to try something wild
fun stuff
had me on the ropes
all right so we got about
10 minutes left in this uh
in this game here steve r19
oh vindy's got mate in one if he wants
it and he's got 11.3 seconds to go
and he got it so vindy is successful so
that
nullifies my uh my two points
so right now we would be tied
0 2
2 0. all right what else we got
we got im rounder
so far they have a half each
i think we got some bad
news for us
our ringer from color art 10122
this round and i know
maybe swap i think tied with
his guys so
so right now there's only one game
remaining in the merits bearer match
and uh bear is up five and a half
to three and a half so you know what
that means bear
has won and they might actually win the
whole
the whole event tonight wwt
might might might might have a chance
too let's see what their
uh what their results are all about
hey aditya
the brother of a grand master
i'll see you tomorrow night for the
secret action quads
and maybe even jeopardy at 4
30. you never know you never ever know
all right well let's check out some
scores let's see if our
td nic risco is updating them
round two
ascension has four points no
actually i take it back ascension has
three points to wwt's four
so let's see uh see if they have like
their final game here
all right so this is a huge game for uh
wwt and ascension so wwt
has the lead four to three right now
wwt has the lead over ascension four to
three
old path is playing for wwt
with the black pieces and all he needs
is a draw
or a win to clinch the match victory s
gilmore 999
is not really letting that happen if you
see by the evaluation board they have
them
up by five points and plus three on the
scoreboard
so what is going on here rook attacks
the queen
so wwt is trying to win
the whole event tonight they brought a
lot of people
and uh let's see see what they can do
so is he just going to take back right
unless he's thinking about something
crazy here
but if you see he's in that danger zone
he's got less than two minutes on the
clock while opath only has 34 though
so
and bears 4-3 defeated i am
rounder
the queen is under attack
so i would just move it all right
he's got ideas maybe of pushing this
pawn
and now this bishop will uh attack oh
i guess they're going to do a queen
trade here
yeah oh oh he's in trouble
made in three let's see if we can see it
i guess you start with this rook check
and king goes here
oh and then it's going to be the old
rook takes a8 checkmate
oh see if you can see it again
check now you can see it
there you go there you go
congratulations to
s gilmore999
with that it's a 4-4 tie
ascension draws wwt
it looks like bear might be victorious
this time around
and as our td said going in they needed
a slew of points
because they started out four five
six in the seventh position with 72 and
a half points but
wow they got 40 just right off the bat
for winning both matches
so they should be doing pretty good
these are not
these are not the actual live scores yet
they're still tabulating them up
and then we'll we'll let you know with
the uh
with the final results
if anybody has a suggestion for the uh
for the best game of the uh day
i am uh i'm all ears
oh look look we got some updated
standings
i don't know if they're official nick
risco
he'll have to say the word
or is he still tabulating
those are the final scores all right
so you see him there bear
bear comes up big time and uh
wins with 58 and a half point that of
course is their
very first victory in the corporate
chess league
they win spring edition number
four wwt right behind
with their draw that really cost them
so as gilmore 999
came up big for not only his team but he
also came up big for bear
and uh so wwt right behind with 55
enterprise they must have got a nice win
in their uh second match
in round two against express scripts
43 and a half i got an i got a feeling
that express scripts will not
be in the final four or on that side
when it's all said and done tonight
ascension with their big drug
get 39 edward jones rebounded well from
their round one loss against wwt to come
in fifth with 38
merits i guess i could have done a
little bit better in
my first game and maybe maybe we would
have got
some more points but we tried we lost to
the champ
18 and a half points express scripts
eight and a half tough night
umb five doherty four and arko
rounds it out with one point i will be
giving out the uh
the brilliancy prize to to uh
s gilmore999 he uh
he was actually their uh
they're uh their manager for for this
week and this week
only he was deputized by uh
by their captain nick rigon who was uh
unavailable to play tonight so one not
only did he he
got a team that uh you know came in
fourth place
he also got a huge match clinching draw
so
congratulations to uh s gilmore 999
you can reach out to uh ryan chester or
lauren stewart with the development
department and they'll uh
they'll tell you your grand prize so
congratulations sir
and um if you want to check out the
the adjusted standings after uh
after this uh the fourth edition you can
just go to saint louis chessclub.org
and then go to the join and give and
underneath that
is the corporate chess league there will
be uh the live standings
will be there tomorrow
oh actually oh hot off the presses
uh we are going to have now these are
not
my come or verified though so
we will have the uh the live standings
and of course
you want to be on the left side of the
screen
and so there's only one edition left
that'll be may 6th and
uh and so let's check it out edward
jones
271 and a half so they've got their spot
a-okay wwt
170 and a half they haven't clinched
anything yet
enterprise 164 and a half
bear 131 and look at how close
ascension is because of that last round
draw against wwt they have
130 points express scripts
they they came in fourth but they still
are within striking distance to get into
the uh
the final four express scripts with 119
points
merits 108 and a half
they're going to have to do a lot of
work in that fifth and final match
in order to make up the ground there
might be too many people to pass
dougherty 89 arko 44 and umb with
9. so very exciting stuff
please tune in may 6th at
about 6 12 usa central time
to see who actually does lynch their
ticket
to the final four good night
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st
louis chess club